les mineurs à paris ils veulent
réactiver le charbon des cévennes
l'innovation nouveau slogan des patrons
pour leurs assises nationales messieurs
bonsoir des scènes déchirantes tout à
l'heure en espagne au moment des
funérailles des petites victimes de la
catastrophe dors tu es là la pluie ne
cesse de battre dans le pays basque
espagnol et cela rend encore plus
lugubre l'atmosphère de cette petite
cité minière près de bilbao qui enterre
déjà ces morts ils sont moins nombreux
qu'on ne l'avait dit dans un premier
temps hier soir mais le bilan est très
lourd difficilement supportable 48
petits enfants et trois adultes
gérard ine la petite localité de retrait
l' intérêt cet après midi quarante huit
de ses enfants âgés de 5 à 7 en silence
recueillement dans cette petite vallée
où la mort a frappé hier un peu avant
midi
la pluie a contrarié cette cérémonie qui
devait être célébrée en plein air sur la
place principale de la ville
le fils funèbre a eu lieu dans cet
entrepôt tous les habitants de retrouver
là étaient présents à cette cérémonie
rejoint par les membres du gouvernement
basque autonome le gouverneur de la
province représentait le gouvernement
espagnol
tandis que se déroulait la cérémonie les
médecins tentaient toujours d'arracher à
la mort
les blessés les plus grièvement atteints
ce soir l'enquêté s'oriente vers
l'hypothèse d'un refus d'agrément
cuisine gaz qui aurait provoqué la
déflagration
oui la reine d'espagne s'est rendu sur
les lieux désir soirée le président
giscard d'estaing guen a dressé une un
télégramme de condoléances au roi juan
carlos un joli coup pour la police ce
soir la police qui n'a pas été épargné
ces dernières semaines et bien la douane
et une dizaine d'inspecteurs de la
brigade de répression du banditisme ont
récupéré un petit trésor de quelque 10
millions de francs chez 4 recéleurs 35
kilos de bijoux en or fin les milliers
de colliers de bracelets de broches de
pendentifs etc
il a fallu une longue filature aux
policiers pour retrouver ce butin dont
on ne sait toujours pas d'où il provient
pierrefonds
un vrai trésor d'ali baba chaîne broche
brasse les gourmettes par kilo de quoi
faire pâlir la favorite d'un palais des
mille et une nuits en attendant ce
fabuleux butin de plus d'un milliard de
centimes nous est agréablement présenté
à la direction générale des douanes
sa récupération est le fruit d'une
enquête de plusieurs semaines qui marque
la collaboration entre la brigade de
répression du banditisme dirigée par le
commissaire divisionnaire devos et la
direction nationale des enquêtes
douanières menée par monsieur gabriel
bastien le trésor a été retrouvée chez
une prostituée à paris et une partie des
bijoux serait d'origine italienne et
proviendrait entre autres d'un hold up
dans la région de vincenzo quatre
personnes ont été arrêtées pour
l'instant de france est déjà fiché par
la police
un belge de la région d'anvers surnommé
l'expert surnom de circonstance qui
venait probablement évaluer les bijoux
une femme était également parmi les
personnes arrêtées
mais elle vient d'être relâché par le
juge d'instruction nous avons été amené
la légendaire cherche à la direction
nationale les enquêtes douanières à
intervenir
avant-hier soir si ma mémoire est bonne
sur
un certain nombre de gens qui procèdent
à des opérations irrégulières au plan
douanier l'importation de bijoux et au
cas présent il y avait sur l'ensemble
des gens interpellés 35 kg d'or 18
carats travail et d'une valeur
approximative en bijouterie si l'on sait
que le gramme d'or en bijouterie est à
320 francs le gramme
si vous multipliez par 34 kg 939 1920
vous vous avez immédiatement la valeur
de d'une partie de la marchandise qui
vous est présentée il est assez
difficile de donner la provenance et
chaque pays
procède à partir du grand banditisme des
opérations frauduleuses qui sont
d'ailleurs dû ressort presque à chaque
fois du grand banditisme en dehors des
frontières du pays où ils commettent les
infractions si vous voulez on fabrique
le produit dans un état en le stock dans
un autre état pour le négocier dans un
troisième et un dans l'état actuel des
choses vont penser qu' il y aura
d'autres saisies de bijoux ça vous savez
si vous me le souhaitez nous on en
accepte l'auguré avec monsieur monsieur
davos un dernier conseil si vous êtes
tenté par ce trésor n'allait pas à la
direction générale des douanes signé
déjà plus pologne les esprits ne sont
pas complètement apaisées
le syndicat indépendance solidarité a
bien officiellement été enregistrés mais
dans une certaine confusion d'autorité
le tribunal a procédé à une modification
des statuts relatif au rôle du parti
communiste et développement avec bruno
end c'est la journée de la confusion
lorsque le président du tribunal de
varsovie entre cet après midi dans la
salle d'audience on croit que celle
épilogue dans la sphère de la création
des syndicats libres
le magistrat s'apprête à lire l'arrêté
qui légalise les syndicats solidarité on
suppose que le texte définitif est le
fruit d'un compromis en particulier
qu'une astuce a été trouvé pour que les
statuts de solidarité reconnaissait à
demi mot le rôle dominant du parti
polonais devant l'air walesa et de
nombreux débris et le président du
tribunal
étonnamment mal à l'aise proclame
l'enregistrement de la nouvelle
organisation n'est que sa décision et
annoncez la salle et plaques en
applaudissements
mais l'euphorie fait rapidement place à
la détection la ch'ti frayeur richard
kelly
et on fait à peine levé que les
responsables syndicaux dénoncent des
changements apportés in extremis dans
les statuts du syndicat
et ce soir l'enregistrement sur temps
acquis de solidarité loin de faire
tomber la fièvre sociale relance
l'incertitude jour les jours qui
viennent sans polonais l'espagne une
nouvelle arrestation vos rêves à forest
et pour son mari dramaturge alfonso
sastre
on ne sait trop pour quelle raison et la
forêt savait déjà été incarcéré
longuement sous le régime franquiste
bréville la france va prêter un milliard
de dollars soit plus de 4 milliards de
francs à brasilia c'est le plus gros
prêt jamais consenti par des banques
françaises au brésil
et c'est delphine menée tôt le ministre
brésilien du plan qui a signé l'accord
cet après midi à paris et puis il rend
khoramshahr est peut-être tombé c'est en
tout cas ce que dit des irakiens
khoramshahr c'est la route d'aba dans
c'est à dire celle du pétrole iranien
serge me serait selon bagdad le général
kir à la ministre irakienne la défense a
annoncé cet après midi par téléphone
président saddam hussein la nouvelle de
la prise complète de la ville de
khoramshahr après qu'elle ait été
nettoyé les dernières poches de
résistance fait citation l'armée
irakienne à siègerait maintenant le
complexe pétrolier d'abadan téhéran a
démenti la nouvelle en reconnaissant
toutefois que des combats de rue se
poursuivait encore ce soir à khoramshahr
l'armée irakienne serait contenue dans
le secteur du pont qui enjambe le fleuve
le fleuve karoun à la sortie de la ville
vers à badens la chute de khoramshahr si
elle était confirmée pourrait signifier
à moyen terme la mainmise irakiennes sur
la province du khouzistan et la perte
par l'iran de sa principale ressource
le pétrole dans ce cas mais traiter à l'
exécution sa menace de mines et le
détroit d'ormuz
que ferait alors les deux grands autant
de questions qui restent posées
quant au sort des deux otages quelques
pas en avant de la part du parlement
iranien qui semble désormais décidée en
viser une solution politique à cette
affaire mais les religieux ont répété
qu'ils ne troqueraient pas les otages
contre des armes
mais avec des mineurs aujourd'hui lancé
par la cgt et la cfdt il faut une
relance charbonnières ont dit les
manifestants de la cgt avec georges
tilly il faut fixer les objectifs de
production par nuit et par bassin pour
en arriver à un chiffre de 30 millions
de tonnes par an a ajouté la cfdt
point névralgique de ses revendications
syndicales le bassin des cévennes qui
est en train de se fermer
progressivement et ses lacets fait j'en
paye eux il ya deux mois ferme et
saint-jean-de-valériscle et le martinet
le bassin comptait 21 filles à la
libération il en reste deux fermes et
molière et rochebelle de 21 mille le
nombre des mineurs est tombé à 14 cents
la fermeture se poursuit saint florent
en 75 ricard le dernier en 78 le mineur
de fond qui sort de tonnes par jour
n'est pas rentable dit la direction on
n'embauche plus on incite les mineurs à
partir en retraite dans d'autres bassins
ou encore à se reconvertir dans
l'industrie une partie ils sont sans
travail en plein air ici à mercoirol ou
leur rendement est cette fois plus grand
l'objectif c'est 250 mille tonnes par an
soit la moitié de ce qu'on extrait
actuellement dans les cévennes
quant au fond il doit fermer bientôt
avant dernière étape la fin de destival
300 mineurs les survivants d'un puits
qui en compte après 2010 appelle à la
conversion la au goût des autres ses
fonds propres gearing tout l'été revient
avec l'aide de l'état subventions prêts
spéciaux le bassin à créer des emplois
si milan 20 ans mais il en a perdu
treize mille le plan du grand sud-ouest
apporte de nouvelles aides surtout pour
les routes
ainsi 16 millions pour la rocade d'alès
mais aussi pour les logements sans
rénover cette année c'est le productif
qu'il faut aider s'étonnent les cévenols
comme la centrale du fesc qui fournit du
courant à edf
or au lieu de la rénover on veut la
fermer et envoyer le charbon en provence
qui enverra l'électricité à alès où est
la rentabilité
si c'était les amitiés l'industrie
privée des charbonnages en tenant à la
main des entreprises et les capitaux
façon les portes là bas il a la
possibilité d'assortir 2002 5 et
l'altruisme
on nous dit qu'on est pas rentable mais
prenez en france que quelques cadeaux
rentable sinon par une allemagne
précisément avec sept autres secteurs en
difficulté et la sidérurgie vous d'hiver
entière gaston tourner le président en
exercice des neufs avaient décidé de
convoquer d'urgence et européen samedi à
luxembourg la raison précisément
l'intransigeance de bonnes que nous
explique michel meyer comme nombre
d'autres la sidérurgie allemande vit des
heures plutôt sombre ce qui n'empêche
pas les patrons d'outre-rhin de ne pas
croire aux lumières de bruxelles en fait
et depuis une dizaine d'années les
grands de l'acier allemands n'ont cessé
de se moderniser de restructurer et
comme ils disent de dégraisser leurs
entreprises ce faisant la sidérurgie
allemand de reste malgré la crise l'une
des plus rentables et des plus
compétitifs du monde quant au niveau de
ses prix surtout pour les aciers dits
nobles le chacun pour soi la loi du
marché reste donc pour les allemands le
cadre le moins défavorable pour défendre
leurs intérêts c'est dire que vu de la
ruhr où de bonnes tout contingentement
de la production et d'entrée perçus
comme une sorte de pénalisation
les allemands se battent donc depuis dix
jours entre un dirigisme qui estime-t-il
et de façon plutôt désobligeantes
avantage trop les canards boiteux
subventionné de l'europe des nains
si l'on ajoute à ces facteurs le fait
que l'actuel ministre de l'économie de
bonnes lecomte lansdorff est un partisan
inconditionnel de l'économie de marché
et qu'il voit rouge dès qu'ils voient
s'approcher un fonctionnaire a fortiori
européen du sinn
eh bien on a fait l'inventaire d'un peu
tous les éléments qui expliquent le blog
le blocage germanique actuelle il reste
que l'on s'efforce ici de ne pas
transformer une crise que l'on
reconsidérer de façon presque impérative
comme essentiellement technique et
économique en une crise politique crise
politique avec menace du droit de veto
d'utilisation du droit de veto et
menacent également de politique de la
chaise vide
en fait et selon des informations
recueillies ici au sommet il semblerait
que les allemands entendent surtout
déboucher sur un compromis qui soit plus
favorable aux industriels allemands
autant ce qui concerne le plafonnement
de la production d'acier que la durée de
ce plafonnement à cet égard les
allemands seraient déjà satisfait si on
limitait la durée ce plafonnement
jusqu'à fin mars 80 et non pas jusqu'à
fin juin 80 comme le souhaite la
commission de bruxelles économie
toujours avec l'élastique du cnp à
strasbourg assises consacré vous le
savez à l'innovation innovation consacré
à les qualifier par françois ceyrac
d'antenne 2010 de véritable assurance
vie de l'entreprise
l'innovation c'est par exemple ce choix
d'un fabricant de jumelles d'un genre
tout à fait spéciale qui vont permettre
la nuit de voir la nuit n'est pas
totalement noir
il existe encore des grains de lumière
qui se propage normalement donc
l'information est là mais là il n'est
pas assez sensible pour la capter d'où
l'idée de mettre un intensificateurs de
hier entre la scène observée ellug de
l'observateur c'est un petit tube qui
mesure 1 mm 5 à peu près d'épaisseur
total devant ce petit tube rond mais un
objectif analogue à celui de l'appareil
de celui d'un appareil photographique et
forment une image donc de la scène à
l'entrée du tube on transforme cette
image de photonique en image
électronique en un temps si si l'image
électronique et on retransforme à la
sortie du tube en images donc visible
par l'oeil d'observateurs
maintenant nous allons donc vous montrer
un enregistrement qui illustre le
résultat de notre réalisation
alors nous avons été dans les sous bois
de la forêt de fontainebleau
vous pourrez remarquer sur les images
que les arbres ont des feuilles c'est à
dire la nuit était prêt noir en fait un
exemple tout à fait typique d'un
problème bien posée et du travail en
commun et physiciens du laboratoire des
électroniciens des opticiens des
mécaniciens une séquence qu'on peut voir
leur dirai tout à l'heure les 2000
patrons réunis à strasbourg
l'innovation c'est aussi et peut-être
surtout l'informatique l'informatique
qui va peut-être faire son entrée dans
l'enseignement tout cas c'est ce que
souhaite un rapport remis aujourd'hui au
chef de l'état son auteur jean claude
simon propose de faire de cette matière
une discipline nouvelle est obligatoire
pour tous les élèves de l'enseignement
général georges leclercq ses enfants
dans quelques années auront à vivre dans
un monde complètement différent du nôtre
le monde de l'informatique pour les
préparer à ce monde nouveau
c'est dès maintenant qu'il faut s'y
prendre qu'il faut leur enseigner le
maniement mais aussi la compréhension
des ordinateurs ce sont eux les plus
réceptifs ce sont eux aussi qui en
bénéficieront le plus les bons et les
mauvais élèves et cela autant au moins
que leurs professeurs ordinateur devrait
être un moyen pour les mettre pour aider
les maîtres pour donner des espèces de
répétition à ses enfants et l'expérience
a montré en particulier à l'étranger que
ces moyens étaient les moyens
excessivement puissant est valable pour
rattrape
et ces fameuses capacités de base
c'est-à-dire pour essayer de remettre
les gens à niveau alors c'est une
évolution que je fais utiliser des
moyens informatiques de façon a essayé
de ressortir les enfants en difficulté
est ce que la france à votre avis est en
retard ou en avance dans l'informatique
dans l'enseignement d'informatique
alors la france a fait beaucoup
d'expériences excessivement est
intéressante mais ces expériences n'ont
pas touché un très grand nombre de gens
alors maintenant le problème est un
problème d'ailleurs de gouvernement
c'est un problème politique
il va s'agir de savoir si on va faire le
saut et si on le voit véritablement
rentrer dans une informatique pour tout
le monde
comment vous pouvez faire pour des gens
qui n'ont jamais approché de près ou de
loin un appareil de ce genre un an un
ordinateur quelle que soit sa taille
oui alors il faut bien faire attention
vous avez deux types d'informatique vous
avez une informatique ou effectivement
novatrice créatrice c'est celle de je
vous l'écrivais et puis alors vous avez
l'informatique que j'appellerais presse
bouton une informatique qui celle qui
sera à cacher dans les voitures bientôt
qui est caché dans les caisses
enregistreuses si vous voulez cacher
dans les jeux d'échecs
vous l'avez simplement besoin de savoir
appuyer sur le bouton donc là il n'y a
pas vraiment essentiellement de
formation à avoir un peu plus tôt dans
la matinée le président république avait
signé la loi sur la distribution aux
salariés d'actions des entreprises
distributions gratuites aux salariés
donc de 3% du capital les entreprises
dans lesquelles ils travaillent
commentaire du président peu à peu nous
ferons des français les propriétaires de
la france son premier ministre était
aujourd'hui en tunisie pour une visite
de travail et d'amitié je cite c'est
maurice werther qui nous en raconte
réparer ce matin en voyage de travail et
d'amitié
aujourd'hui apparaissent surtout les
démonstrations protocolaire la tunisie
est un grand pays ni par la taille ni
par la population 6 millions d'habitants
mais c'est un pays politiquement très
important deux exemples où deux preuves
c'est à tunis que siègent maintenant la
ligue arabe dont le secrétaire général
monsieur libye est tunisien le
secrétaire général de la conférence
islamique qui joue et c'est de jouer le
rôle de conciliateur entre l'irak et
l'iran
son secrétaire général monsieur chaput
est tunisienne voilà qui situe déjà la
tunisie au coeur de la politique
moyen-orientale et monsieur bara étaient
très satisfaits de constater que presque
sur tous ces points il est d'accord avec
le premier ministre tunisien monsieur
moselle
quant aux relations franco tunisiennes
elles se développent harmonieusement
on va créer ainsi une banque
d'investissement franco tunisienne avec
des capitaux français aussi des capitaux
en provenance des pays arabes pétroliers
amorce de trilogue cela pour financer le
sixième plan tunisien de développement
industriel en échange de quoi
une bonne partie des avoirs français
gelé en tunisie seront progressivement
débloqués pour les petits possédants
autrement dit le contentieux franco
tunisien comme on dit est en bonne voie
d'être liquidé les présidentielles où la
présidentielle comme vous voudrez marie
france garaud ira le plus loin possible
elle ne désespère pas d'obtenir ses 500
signatures nécessaires
donc pour être candidate elle l'a dit
tout à l'heure sur rtl candidature
diversement accueillies dans la majorité
rien ou rpr témoigné un jeu intéressant
pour jean le calvez à lui ds candidature
podium pour jacques blanc au parti
républicain et puis du côté du pc
finalement dimanche à marseille que
françois mitterrand en dire un peu plus
sinon sur l intention du moins sur sa
réaction à la candidature rocard enfin
ce jugement de jean marie le pen
la vème république est en train de vivre
son agonie et puis la suite du budget à
l'assemblée après l'armée hier
l'éducation deuxième par ordre
d'importance lorenzen avec 101 milliards
673 millions de francs le budget de
l'éducation pour 1981
est après celui de la défense le second
des budgets soit 16,6 pour cent des
dépenses de l'état on note cependant une
régression de près de 3%
puisque l'an dernier sa part était de
17% son augmentation est inférieure à
celle du budget général
il s'agit donc d'un budget de
reconduction qui tient compte de la
nouvelle baisse des effectifs dans les
écoles primaires les dépenses de
personnel absorbe près de 90 % des
crédits leur augmentation tient
essentiellement à la hausse des
rémunérations
en effet si près de 2000 postes sont
créés il résulte principalement de la
titularisation d'auxiliaires le nombre
réel de nouveaux emplois et de 200 ainsi
la création de postes d'enseignants
continue de s'amenuiser
en revanche 12 millions de francs seront
spécialement affectés à la formation des
maîtres l'aide aux enfants en difficulté
et l'action culturelle donc à des
améliorations qualitatives
comme l'annoncé le ministère pour les
crédits de fonctionnement leur eau sera
en fait absorber par le coût du
chauffage et de l'électricité
les dépenses en faveur de l'action
sociale 4% également augmente au profit
des transports scolaires
mais les bourses elles sont en
diminution quant aux crédits affectés
aux investissements 3%
ils sont consacrés à l'entretien et la
réparation des locaux scolaires sans
constructions nouvelles
il faut signaler enfin que seule la part
de l'enseignement privé augmente de
façon conséquente + 22% en application
de la loi guermeur de 77
afin d'assurer aux enseignants du privé
le même statut que dans le secteur
public
jean qu'ayant exclus du pc vous savez
que ce protestataires communiste avait
appelé ses camarades à ne pas voter pour
georges marchais il avait été accusé
hier par la marseillaise quotidien
communiste de marseille dans leur a
collé pour françois mitterrand 60 km de
tours de plus pour ceux qui se rendent
en bretagne l'autoroute du mans et
depuis tout à l'heure prolongée jusqu'à
rennes jusqu'à une voie rapide
et puis pour terminer ce journal une
page musicale en compagnie du jeune
pianiste daniel vassallo daniel
arsenault s'est imposé très vite en
france et au delà des frontières
l'académie du disque l'a couronné l'an
dernier et aujourd'hui il consacre ses
enregistrements et ses concerts à jean
sébastien bach
on pourra l'écouter au théâtre des
champs elysées le 4 novembre prochain en
attendant pour ce portrait nylon sportif
de gagner le barça nord réalisé par
george d
après avoir enregistré les oeuvres
d'eric satie l'année dernière daniel
barça nous vient de s'attaquer à jean
sébastien bach
à 26 ans il est déjà entré dans le
cercle très fermé des grands
concertistes depuis l'âge de 20 ans il
court de new york à tokyo de madrid à
paris deux récitals en festive élèves en
france de pierre sancan à los angeles de
rosalie naturex est un lutteur il ne
néglige ni les efforts pour se rendre
maîtres une partition ni les contacts
avec la presse car il sait
qu'aujourd'hui une carrière de musicien
ne se construit pas seulement dans les
salles de concert il sait aussi que
jouer du piano
plusieurs heures par jour rejoints
quelques fois la performance sportive
il arrive un moment où on s'aperçoit que
on fait de la musique comme on fait
l'amour
il faut être faut prendre l'instrument à
bras le corps et donc il faut avoir le
corps et l'esprit complètement
disponible et est complètement souple
alors il faut il faut avoir un dos en v
très bon état faut avoir des gens qui
vous porte et des bras musclés donc il
faut faire du tueur il faut ce qu'il
faut respirer et il faut ne pas ne pas
venir reste est resté jeune renfort dans
notre société est ce que bach n'est pas
quelque chose d'un peu dépassée
qu'est-ce qui vous apportent qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent apporter baquet est un
ressort
c'est une fontaine de jouvence c'est une
musique pleine d'énergie plein de joie
qui reflètent la vie du compositeur qui
a une vie
extraordinairement familiale paisible
quart équilibré et on a besoin
aujourd'hui de cet équilibre de cet
oxygène de ce ciel bleu besoin également
pour daniel bard sano de peintures
d'objets sacrés autour de lui témoin de
la foi est porteur d'espérance
et
voilà une petite rectification à ce que
nous disions tout à l'heure eva forest
il ya d'être relâché donc elle avait été
arrêtée en vertu d'une loi
antiterroriste et la forêt a été relâché
en espagne de nouveaux journaux la
presse foisonnent en ce moment que je
vous laisse découvrir les courts madame
qui est une fille de l'écho de notre
temps et puis harmonica magazine qui est
un hebdomadaire qui va magazine qui va
être lancée par albert raisner
l'ensemble donc dans les kiosques à
venir et puis pour terminer tout à fait
et ce journal une réflexion non pas sur
la météo mais sur la condition juive une
réflexion qui nous a été inspirée bien
sûr par l'attentât de la rue copernic
mais aussi par ce livre que vient de
publier
alain finkielkraut et qui s'appelle le
juif imaginaire
philippe harrouard a tracé un portrait
de cet auteur qui s'inscrit donc en
plein dans l'actualité
toute ma vie je me suis affirmé juif je
n'ai pas connu de moments où je voulais
cacher cette identité comme une honte
mais je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
réduit le judaïsme à un personnage le
personnage de l'homme souffrant meurtri
du juste et que ce personnes ce
personnage me fascinait à tel point que
pour moi le judaïsme c'était rien
d'autre que de mid de m'identifier à lui
de m'approprier voracement son image
gratifiante et heureuse et j'ai voulu et
c'est ce que c'est cela que j'appelle le
juge imaginaire
l'auteur de ces nouvelles réflexions sur
la question juive alain finkielkraut à
31 ans agrégé de lettres il s'est mis en
congé l'université pour travailler à
tenir
à ces reportages le juif imaginaire
cache derrière un titre choc
1 et c'est sincère et courageux une
réponse à la question juive
judaïsme en tant que peuple ne se range
pas aussi aisément qu'on le croyait dans
les catégories habituelles
il y à l'état d'israël mais le judaïsme
déborde l'état d'israël donc n'est pas
un état nation et qu'est ce que c'est
j'ai entendu un rabbin lorsque j'étais à
jérusalem ravin qui est à la fois un
rabbin et âme et un mathématicien me
dire c'est une méta famille c'est à dire
quelque chose comme une famille au delà
de la famille j'accepterai assez bien
cette définition ce que je rejette mois
précisément c'est toutes les puissances
d'oubli tout ce qui pourrait nous amener
à dire le génocide ça n'a pas bien
d'importance la culture qui précédait le
génocide ça n'a pas eu d'importance
la tradition juive dans la mesure
aujourd'hui elle est monopolisé par
l'orthodoxie ça n'a pas d'importance non
je crois que être juif aujourd'hui c'est
s'efforcer de retrouver contact avec
cela est-ce que vous pensez que votre
livre peut apporter une réponse aux
réflexions qui ont suivi l'attentât de
la rue copernic ce serait peut-être un
peu arrogant de dire puisque mon livre a
été écrit avant et que moi même je ne
sais pas très bien encore ce qu'il se
passe aujourd'hui je constate
effectivement que l'affirmation juive a
été très forte
ils ont les gens n'ont pas eu peur n'ont
pas cédé et juifs vont pas céder au
chantage de l'assimilation s'écraser
laisser passer l'orage cette attitude là
qui était celle des juifs pendant
l'affairé dreyfus a complètement disparu
je constate aussi que il y a eu un un
phénomène de solidarité a fait que la
classe politique et avec l'église
la presse que que les juifs non plus
n'ont jamais connu donc si on prend une
perspective historique l'époque pour les
juifs et plus sûr cela dit il y a
effectivement un climat assez malsain
aujourd'hui que je ne suis pas sûr de
bien caractérisé mais par exemple quand
j'ai vu tous ces gens dire oh là là on
en fait trop sur copernic vraiment
on s'est un fait divers et puis tout le
monde s'émeut là j'ai commencé à être
inquiet parce que quand les gens disent
cela ils disent alors si on en fait
tellement c'est que les juifs sont très
puissants et les juifs deviennent
faibles et fragiles
quand beaucoup de gens sont persuadés
qu'ils sont puissants la météo donc elle
est arrivée les températures à 13 heures
étaient dans l'ensemble élevé toutefois
un début de refroidissement se faisait
sentir sur le nord-ouest alors demain
dans voici cette diapositive de demain
le temps sera variable sur tout le
territoire les éclaircies seront plus
marquées d'une part de la bretagne à
l'aquitaine notre part sur le languedoc
et la provence
les passages nuageux avec averses
prédominant dans le nord-est le centre
est les alpes et les pyrénées puis les
vents de nord-ouest à nord faible à mort
est pas modéré seront assez forts sur le
languedoc et la basse vallée du rhône
température subiront il faut le dire une
baisse assez importante de 3 à 6 degrés
par rapport à celles d'aujourd'hui
votre dernier journal est après
apostrophe vers 23h donc un petit peu
avant en tout cas 20h50 avec harry
claude et puis l'invité vingtaine de
midi demain ce sera ferhat abbas puis à
20h vous retrouverez léon zitrone
bonne soirée à tous à l'aise